[Music]
today is Wednesday or as General
Petraeus calls it hump day what else is
walking study was just released Andy
what was it Conan I'm not doing this
anything I can't cope on okay I thought
we were shooting an infomercial how much
would you pay for the next joke Andy I'd
probably pay 30 $40
how about $9.99 what oh my gosh no
snooze study came out according to a new
study humans may be gradually losing
their intelligence the study was
conducted by watching four minutes of
here comes honey boo boo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy story I can't believe this is true
a petition for Texas to secede from the
United States has gotten over 25,000
signatures yeah these the signatures are
from every state but Texas
[Applause]
[Music]
we are guests holidays coming up you're
getting ready Andy oh sure I am Conan
you're the worst guy I ever met
blood Conan I can't wait for this next
video well I'll tell you Ricky are you
gonna love it for the holidays you're
ostensibly here to support me
for the holidays the makers of Pringles
are coming out with a white chocolate
peppermint flavored potato chip
in a in a related story Pfizer is coming
out with cinnamon flavored insulin so
we're gonna balance itself out a quart
core hey according to a new study of
emergency rooms the number one way
people injure their genitals is riding
their bicycle also the number one lie
people tell in emergency rooms is I was
riding my bicycle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]